All these cover letters are the same, I need to try something new.
To whom it may concern, in regards to your job that I yearn.
For weeks I've tried to launch a career and all I can do is persevere.
I'll convey my qualifications through this acoustic guitar iteration.
So pencil in some notes, you better, this ain't your cliche cover letter.
Went to Bentley University, got summa cum laude in a marketing degree.
As for skills, I'm pretty darn creative, detail-focused and mighty persuasive.
I'm a middle child with a sister and a brother so it's no surprise I work well with others.
I had four internships, all of them unpaid.
Not really what you want when you got financial aid.
So hire me, yeah, yeah.
But I won't work for free, no, no.
I'll bring value to your company.
So hire me.
I've done some projects on the side like marketing for GreatPaths and SocialVibe.
Conducted focus groups in Bentley's CMT or worked with president, founder and VP.
So in conclusion, I've had some experience.
I'm confident in my abilities, for serious.
I've got a lot to offer just give me a position.
To your team, I'll make a solid addition.
Went to Bentley University, got summa cum laude in a marketing degree.
I also do graphic design on Photoshop with pointers I picked up from my illustrator pop.
Took four semesters of Japanese...
...that might be of interest if your company is overseas.
And that's all I've really got to say in this musical cover letter slash resume.
So hire me, yeah, yeah.
But I won't work for free, no, no.
I'll bring value to your company.
So hire me.
Oh yeah, hire me.